[Music]
hello Su TV family and friends again we
welcome you to I'd like to know our
Bible question and answer program and we
love this program because gets us gives
us a chance to sort of Reach Out And
Touch you as You Reach Out And Touch us
with your questions and your comments
from the word of God so we thank you for
being a part of this program by sending
in your questions that we get the chance
to answer from the word of God should
you like to have a question answered we
encourage you to do so by writing To Us
by contacting us at TVM tv.org that is
tvtv
.or G and we make you this promise two
promises we make one that we will get to
them just as soon as we can and two when
we do get to them our answers will come
from The Trusted word of God that is the
promise that we make because your time
is too valuable to hear men's opinion
you need an opinion from the word of God
and that's what we pledge to give you
when you write us I'm in the company of
Pastor David Salazar and Pastor Steven
bore my name is CA Murray and and again
it is exciting for us to answer your
questions may I encourage you when you
write us let us know where you are
writing from what country what city if
you wish but give us some general idea
where you're writing from it helps us to
know what the footprint of the ministry
is and where we can be of assistance to
you so include that little little detail
if you will and we thank you in advance
Pastor Salazar if you would give us uh a
word of prayer then we will launch out
into our questions for this day
absolutely let us pray Heavenly Father
we come before you to thank you for the
opportunity that you give us to study
your word to seek in it the answers to
our questions and we ask now that you
will uh anoint us with your holy spirit
so that we receive the power from on
high to respond and give answers that
are according to your will and that will
bring the hearers and the listeners
closer to you to an understanding of
your love and of your work
in ways that they will understand and
live in lives of Victory we thank you
for your grace we pray this in Jesus
name amen amen and amen all right our
first question for this particular
program comes from a country that you
have a little bit of familiar with
familiarity with that is from Magda from
Uruguay um yes congratulations on your
wonderful program well thank you very
much God bless you deeply I'd like to
know why at the beginning of the Book of
Matthew under the title genealogy of
Jesus we find the family lines of Joseph
uh who wasn't the biological father of
Jesus and not the genealogy of Mary who
was his biological mother uh she states
is there a genealogy of Mary
somewhere all right well the first
question that she has is why is the
genealogy of the line of Joseph
mentioned in Matthew and we can actually
see the there is about um 17 verses the
first 17 verses of the Matthew genealogy
in Matthew chapter 1 that states how
Jesus was the son of David then the son
of and up to the son of Abraham that's
where it stops there uh and then Matthew
makes this very clear distinction to
mention that are 14 Generations between
Abraham to David and from David to um
SEL and from SEL to Joseph who was the
adopted father of Jesus and the reason
why uh the genealogy is mentioned there
Matthew puts this genealogy is probably
in the sense that he wants to present
the lineage of Jesus as one who was
indeed of the lineage of Abraham of
David and so it's it's important to us
to understand that even though Jesus was
not the biological son of Joseph in many
or all the Genies of the Bible the males
are the ones that are named of each
individual it was not the females or the
mothers that are necessarily mentioned
in genealogies but mainly the fathers
and in this sense even though Jesus was
a son by adoption to Joseph legally
speaking
he was considered in the records as a
son of Joseph this is how we see in the
Bible after you know several times where
people would say isn't he the son of
Joseph the carpenter so legally speaking
Jesus was the son of Joseph and legally
Matthew presents the genealogy of how
Jesus was indeed uh a legal son to
Joseph now the answer to the other
question I'm going to let Pastor bore
answer this question where is the
genealogy of Mary to prove that Jesus
was not just by legal declaration as son
of of Joseph and of David rather but how
through the genology of Mary she he is
the son of David the son of Abraham even
the son of Adam Son of
God well uh the book of Romans tells us
very clearly Romans chap 1 and I'll read
verses 1 to 3 three Paul a bond servant
of Jesus Christ called to be an apostate
separated to the gospel of God which he
promised before through His prophets in
the Holy scriptures now comes the key
verse concerning his son Jesus Christ
Our Lord who was born of the seed of
David according to the flesh MH now
Jesus did not get his flesh through
Joseph right the text says got his flesh
through Mary mhm and so and so uh he had
a right to the throne both from Joseph
legally MH and from Mary according to
the flesh right Ellen Way confirms this
uh when she's talking about Joseph and
Mary having to go to uh Bethlehem
because of the census uh she wrote uh
she wrote this she is of the lineage of
David and the son of David must be born
in David's City MH so she is the of the
lineage of davidh out of Bethlehem said
the prophet shall he come forth that is
to be ruler in Israel whose goings forth
have been from old from the days of
Eternity but in the city of their Royal
Line Joseph and Mary are unrecognized
and unhonored weary and homeless they
Traverse the entire length of the Narrow
Street from the Gate of the city to the
Eastern extremity of the Town vainly
seeking a resting place for the night uh
so so Ellen White indicates that
according to the flesh Jesus had a right
to the throne because he was born of
Mary and also we have the genealogy in
Luke that is a little different in Luke
chapter 3: 21 and on Luke actually
presents another genealogy that
is uh actually starts off differently
than the one in Matthew and there is a
little bit of an argument in in some of
circles that this is a hard hard to
understand explain it specifically but
we have the understanding that this
actually is a lineage of Mary because
it's quite different in in the in some
of the names that uh don't match with ma
one in Matthew and therefore the
possibility that this is actually look
by inspiration writing to confirm that
Mary is indeed of the mage of David
through the parents through the males as
is the custom it really proves or shows
that Jesus was indeed the son of David
the son of Abraham and this actually
genealogy takes us all the way back to
Adam which is the Son of God so uh
another interesting thing about it is
that you know this galy presents us with
more details and and brings uh the
perhaps other names that are added to
research and find out how Joseph I how
Jesus was rather the son of the lineage
of David and the lineage of God I think
one of the things that we we always need
to ask ourselves when dealing with the
writings of the first four evangelists
is why they wrote and and who was Their
audience uh and that really uh gives you
some context for the detail that they
put in of course Matthew went back to
Abraham the quote first Jew because
Matthew's burden was that Christ was the
Fulfillment of of of all Old Testament
prophecies he was the Fulfillment of
everything that was predicted in the Old
Testament so he started with the Jewish
economy the the first Jew and then
brought it up to the time uh his his his
own time uh Luke's audience was a bit
different and so his the way he uh
attacks this uh issue is again a bit a
bit different but they're both writing
to a particular consist constituency and
they
they sort of skew their their arguments
to meet that constituency uh and so you
do have some some variations because
they're they're trying to prove
different points uh and coming at it
from different aspects and both are
correct yes uh that's the beauty of the
four gospels some people say well why
don't you have just one gospel the fact
is that when you put all of the evidence
from all four gospels together you have
the complete picture indeed of of
Christ's Earthly Soldier yeah um and of
course each gospel writer has their own
way of expressing it and uh there's not
contradictions they're comp they
complement one another said and and so
we should not say well you know the
genealogy in Luke is a contradiction to
the genealogy in chapter 1 of Matthew
bottom line is the only contradictions
uh in the Bible are the ones that are in
our own brain the on that we cre there
are not contradictions in the Bible at
all we just simply have to have to look
at all of the evidence amen um you know
let me give you one example it's not
directly related to this but you know
one gospel writer says that Judas went
uh hanged himself uh and another says
that he fell headlong this is the book
of Acts chapter one fell head long and
his belly split open and his in came out
so you know obviously then uh the gospel
writer and and the writer of the book of
Acts contradicted each other no they
didn't you know Ellen White gives a
perfect explanation and that is that
Judas was a very heavy man you know he
was H going to hang himself over a ledge
the Rope broke and he fell a long
distance and his belly split open but he
still had the intention of committing
suicide so the only contradiction is not
in the biblical text the contradiction
is in our own mind well said well said
uh another thing you can kind of tell
who who they're writing to by little
things uh each gospel writer will give
you a hint if he if the writer is
talking about uh say the Passover and it
says the Passover a feast of the Jews
you can tell that his audience is
non-jewish because if he's writing to a
Jewish audience audience he would not
have to put a feast of the Jews because
every Jew knew what the Passover was so
his audience is non-jewish uh that kind
of thing so if you're reading if you
read with with a little insight you will
find that the author really will kind of
explain to you where he's coming from
and who he's trying to address in in
these kinds of things so it's a it's an
exciting there is a a something to be
gained from a quick reading of the word
of God then there is much to be gained
from a slow verse by verse understanding
of the word of God as you try to digest
it and you will find that the Bible gets
much deeper as you grow in Grace and in
strength and in knowledge the Bible
grows right along with you and grows in
strength and in knowledge you know
another example of this is if you had
only the gospel of
Matthew you might think that Jesus uh
simply came from Abraham and from David
right but John takes you far beyond that
it takes you all the way to begin in the
beginning he already was yes and so and
so fortunately we have the the Gospel of
John to tell us that uh Matthew is
describing the Earthly birth of Christ
but Jesus pre-existed that long a long
time before that you know a question
could be asked and we need to get on to
another question uh if you look at Luke
Chapter 135 the Bible talks about that
Holy thing um we try to give Mary a
little leg up as it were but this was a
this the birth of Christ was a very
special thing unequaled uh and uh by any
other thing in the universe and never
repeated it was one one time deal so we
cannot give Mary full credit nor Joseph
full credit this was something done by
the Holy Spirit and done by God so it's
a very unique uh kind of a situation uh
and an argument could be made is Mary
more his mother than Joseph's father
well this was an implantation by the
Holy Spirit totally different thing uh
One of a Kind never happened before
never happened again God chose the two
best people of the time to be the
parents of Jesus amen amen and amen amen
well done good question um we have no uh
uh location for this I suspect it is
somewhere in Africa because the name is
handsome andu handsome andu thank you so
much writing to us uh I hope I find you
well I'd like to know what is LG white
and our churches stand on prescribed
medication is it wrong to use them or
not as a nurse n am I in the wrong
profession thank you in advance well my
sister is a
nurse and and then retired as a
nurse I don't think she ever believed
she was in the wrong profession to
assist in healing is certainly is not
wrong unless God is calling you to
assist in preaching well then you ought
to be move from nursing to preaching but
but Nur nursing and healing and doctors
are not wrong per per se um uh as long
as we realize realiz that all true
healing comes from the Lord my
mother-in-law when she was sick she
during her last day she said you know I
think I thank God that he's kept me and
the and the the the cardiologist was
incensed Pastor he said
God he said God's not keeping you alive
I'm keeping you alive I'm giving you the
medication I'm I'm he said that and she
was shocked uh that he would take that
credit to himself when uh in the
presence of of a God who himself does
healing so is he in the wrong profession
not because he's a nurse not because
he's a medical professional I think not
way in gentlemen if you
will well the bottom line is that uh the
medical world these days depends on uh
remedies in quotation marks um that
really cause many side effects you know
one of my pet peeves is they're always
inventing new diseases that are consist
that have three letters or four PTSD you
know that kind of thing um and and the
funny thing is and maybe it's not so
funny for the person who is sick is that
uh they give a long list of the side
effects the drug that is produced by
these drugs um there's a better way uh
Ellen White wrote and this is a very
well-known statement but uh the next
paragraph we usually don't focus on uh
Ministry of healing 127 she says pure
air sunlight abstemiousness which is
basically Temperance yes rest exercise
proper diet the use of water trust in
divine power these are the true remedies
every person should have a knowledge of
nature remedial agencies notice Nature's
remedial agencies and how to apply them
them it is essential both to understand
the principles involved in the treatment
of the sick and to have a practical
training that will enable one rightly to
use this knowledge so it's not only
Theory it's practice uh then the next
paragraph says the use of natural
remedies requires an amount of care and
effort that many are not willing to give
if you have a headache it's so much
easier to take an aspirin you know than
to really look for the cause that's not
illen white that's my comment she
continues Nature's process of healing
and upbuilding is gradual mhm and to the
impatient it seems
slow the surrender of hurtful
indulgences requires sacrifice but in
the end it will be found that nature
unrel does her work wisely and well amen
those who are persevere in obedience to
her laws will reap the reward in health
of body and health of
mind so you know the the secret of good
health health is simply to apply these
eight remedies that Ellen White mentions
to know how they function and how to
apply them and to live a healthy
lifestyle I remember when uh the
pandemic when it was just beginning
that I did a video uh on whether people
should get the vaccine or not and uh in
that video I said you need to do three
things to make your personal decision it
was always a personal decision with
Secrets unsealed we never mandated it
for the people in the office you know we
for a period there when it got really
bad we kept some people in the office
and told them to wear a mask and other
people work from home but we always
allowed them to make their own decisions
when it came to the vaccine and uh the
interesting thing is that um I went on
online I we actually put it on our uh
channel for quite a long time um and I
said you need to do three things number
one do your own
research number two speak with your
physician and number three live a
healthy lifestyle following sound
principles so you can keep a strong
immune system system mhm that was the
recommendation of Secrets unsealed we
mentioned the vaccine as an option but
we never recommended that people get the
vaccine or mandated that people get
vaccine uh and so uh Ellen White makes
it clear that knowledge of how Health
Works and practicing the principles and
knowing how to apply them is the way to
go amen there is um you know several
parts in the spirit prophecy that speaks
about as you mentioned Pastor what are
the methods of the Lord wants us to use
what are the recommendations how to live
healthier and there is even a culation
in selected messages volume two and I
will invite our friend to read this
whole paragraph this whole actually uh
chapter that deals with the counil on
the administration of drugs and the
council is it's guided first directly
usually to the Physicians to the doctors
who are the ones responsible you know
sometimes nurses are more at least in
the States you know they don't have the
ability to you know give medication to
anyone they they just follow the
doctor's orders uh to administer the
drugs that are needed uh so in in this
scenario I think it's important that as
a nurse if the you know a friend
handsome you know if he is subject to a
doctor to tell us to prescribe drugs for
his patients you know he needs to
understand that he's doing the job of
providing the assistance that the doctor
recommends but if you are a doctor a
physician or you have the ability to
elect the councils are
to not use drugs as is generally done in
other words just you know without any
research finding out what the conditions
or what's causing the condition of the
person so in that sense she says you
know drugs drug medication as it
generally practiced is a curse educate
educate away from drugs and that's she's
really trying to understand and point
that the way that God wants us to do is
through the natural agencies as you well
mentioned now there is a a understanding
that I want to bring out there's also in
this chapter an example that happened to
a missionary in Australia who his son
died of malaria and he was so certain
that the drug that they use at the time
which was called the
um uh the Quine that drug that was used
at the time Quine Quine thank you Quine
that drug was uh you know for for him
was a sin the the the individual the
missionary thought it was a sin and so
his son died because he didn't
administer that that medication and when
he approached C white and said did I do
wrong not administrating my son the
Quine the answer for her was no I mean
I'm sorry did he was it as would be as
would uh he said would I have sined to
give my son quinine and then the answer
to her from her was no we are expected
to do the best we can
so drugs as a whole you know we cannot
say don't use them the recommendation is
try to use them very less and less if
possible and this is why you have to be
wise if you are a person that has
conditions that have medical conditions
you can just say you know I'm going to
cut off drugs that I've been using you
have to be mindful and and talk to your
physician and doctor and and and find
ways so you can start maybe moving away
from that if your health allows you to
um so it's not a sin to use medications
drugs but God wants us to learn to live
lives where we are not dependent
necessarily and only looking for drugs
as Solutions but trying to maybe change
your lifestyle there are things you
might have to give up you know learn to
rest learn to spend time outside to to
do exercise I mean there are many things
that God has given in our bodies and
through nature to help us to heal to
truly heal and this is where the
emphasis is but I do recommend our
friend to go through that whole chapter
there's a lot of Good Counsel in regards
to how drugs uh are to be you know uh
use or or not use if you will and uh but
ultimately believe the the
recommendation from the Lord is to truly
seek ways where we can regain the health
through the simple principles of nature
that I has given us as human beings
that's the better way you know original
our hospital was called sanitarium
that's right it's a place where people
are healed right uh and the best way to
heal and Kellog understood this MH is
through natural means yes these are all
very very good comments there is much we
can do to help our own health by taking
care of ourselves and following the
prescribed natural remedies for our
health well again our time has slipped
into eternity may God continue to bless
you as we worship Him in spirit and in
truth we'll see you again soon bye-bye
[Music]